again it's back to fighting it's like
when I speaking playing Gabri guns on
the third round exhausted my coaches out
four minutes laughs oh my god if I could
I make time out Hey
oh my god tell me halfway dude formats
is such an eternity Oh would its forever
bright switch when you're so tiny of
this Oh Brazilian man when you're
wrestling is a full round when you're in
high school four minutes left
oh my god was filming dude you [ __ ] me
dude oh don't tired that's so long dude
four minutes four minutes
oh I will never forget that as long as I
live
4-minute can't imagine there's a few
things I'll never forget - I forget who
was I fighting I forget who I was
fighting I've I've been Lavar Johnson I
forget I was coming off a loss and my
coach we like we I went away from Momo
to Jackson I came back sir
it's time together in Loren Landau who's
been with me from the start
who's my train at time he knows me he's
based my best friend but also the best
strength conditioning coach in the world
strength condition coach for the Broncos
now shout out to Lauren so he's with me
and he's sitting in my my old coach is
trying to visualize things fight maybe
just off he's like I want you I want you
to go back to when you fought Roy Nelson
you remember that moment and I'm like
okay I'm like wah I'm like where we
going with this I'm like I'm a mama go
with us I want to remember what you felt
like when he [ __ ] hit you that right
now
was your first loss and I was like okay
and I'm like Gabby's like you're not
feeling like Kelly now I want you to
take yourself to Brazil all right and
you fought would you fight that he for
guys I could you fight there as well big
Nagios that's right so he fought the
legend Nogueira and you're in Brazil you
flew 17 hours I think remember remember
that trip so you're down there right and
the locals were nasty to you can you
take all the sin on like mm-hmm
keep your eyes closed I'm like yeah yeah
giggles so remember that big biggest
fight of your life right and big is fine
your life we flew all the way down there
your families that everybody made
sacrifices get down there so expensive
you didn't make much money
and then again another right hand do you
remember what that felt like I'm all in
my head I'm thinking like yeah he's like
now fast forward past that we're in
Atlanta you'll see and he can't remember
yes there's a tunnel he works and I
caught it so where's he goes there's a
ton of them now so here we are
where Atlanta and fight Ben Rothwell
over 50 fights phenomenal fighter
remember that fight mall in my hand Lee
is he [ __ ] with me right angles we
tell you to take it because we told you
to take it easy dragging the late rounds
but that's not your style
so you come out gentle blazing through a
spinning backfist you wobbled him they
made a huge mistake and you got caught
with a left hand
openly wild wild do you remember that
and I'm like I let me open my eye look
at Lauren Luiz like he's like now once
you take all that I want you bring it to
the cage of that he leaves and me and
Lauren can't stop laughing
I go Jim did he have like an earpiece in
from [ __ ] on the other team
what I go is that glad working knock
that left the one he wanted your three
worst fights your three nightmare fights
yeah well how can we go over any of the
wins but what is really dude we had some
big wins lady come already the win demon
just all to my losses another I want
your picture Brazil I ruined made a ton
of sacrifices you didn't make much money
it's like Oh what I'll do Thanks is so I
will no I agree I would never get that
angry I will never I will never forget
that cuz me and Laura Leigh no we we
could not stop what do you think of
psych coaches I think they're good if if
there's very good there there's a few of
them that's it's like stand up yeah I
think they're good they're good if
they're bad they're really bad yeah they
can own between really if they're good
like I I have gotta get you out of your
way right that's I've just techniques
that you know you gotta you don't but
these techniques might help you along
the way maybe 1% you know but like I
worked at these Navy see these these
guys who trained the Navy SEALs and
Special Forces team when the combat yeah
it was like breathing techniques and
like fighter pilots yeah
there they were great I still do it out
those different stand-up to wake me up
they were trade good stuff yeah so what
what is the breathing technique that you
learned so people can hear about it
oh yeah it's a take forever and really
yeah because all you have like how your
breath controls like so much combat
breathing they call it so much of what
you do from calming your nerves down to
getting you focus to waking you up like
your breath is so and forth on board
yeah no I know because I body
I am body call just clothes because I am
body the hold on so how is this it's
about just kung fu kung fu' yeah you're
saying boom well that's how it said so
as I'm from I studied in China pistol